nowhere in the world is the health of
marine mammals more closely monitored
than the UK not by studying the living
but by examining the dead
these veterinary pathologists are
hardened to grim sights but even they
were shocked by what they found in a
whale stranded and dying on the Isle of
Skye is the stomach
really intestines for
video exclusively given to Sky News
reveals that in its stomach were 45
plastic bags or fragments mistaken for
food and now knotted together here you
see them in the the plastic has Jam
hacked into the intestine this is the
first time the scientists have laid out
the plastic on the floor of their lab
bin bag so you can see the knot it's
household rubbish that's been carelessly
disposed of swept far out to sea and
submerged well below the waves where
beat whales feed for every single one of
these pieces it is possible that there
would have been some form of human
action that could have stopped that
getting into the marine environment
in Norway scientists are investigating
another whale that made headlines when
it came into the shallows to die earlier
this year the same species the same
problem its stomach stuffed with plastic
the scientists counted 30 pieces in
total this time ghostly writing on some
of the bags gave away their origin this
is the remains of somebody's shopping a
wrapper from an ice-cream a bag that
once contained a frozen chicken and this
packaging from the multi pack of crisps
and I can tell from the writing that
it's quite clearly from Britain but it's
been in the water as recently as 2015
and at the bottom two important symbols
one that it could have been recycled and
the other that it should have been
disposed of properly
it's a Walker's wrapper it's only
purpose to bundle together six bags of
crisps do you think that's unnecessary
use of plastic personally I don't know
but of course it's not only the producer
here is it's also us the the consumers
we also have to think about what we're
doing here the company declined to be
interviewed but it said it is
considering changes to its packaging
there in the Canaries scientists have a
theory on why plastic is such a threat
to some whales they are coming to
investigate they're both beautiful we
tracked down a family of beaked whales
at the surface bags don't look much like
food but in the darkness a mile down the
whales hunt with sound waves a mistake
plastic for their natural prey so we are
killing animals with a plastic that will
have lived a long life and they an
animal that can live 16 years to die as
a youngster maybe before it has
reproduced yes because he has hidden
from plastic when he something so easy
to avoid plastic has built up along
Norway's long coastline for many years
rubbish swept on the ocean currents from
as far away as the UK but the death of
the whale has inspired volunteers backed
by the government to mount an
extraordinary cleanup
it's just one country dealing with a
global problem for the harm to marine
animals underlines the need to act
Thomas More Sky News Bergen